salut à tous bienvenue sur une nouvelle
vidéo sur la chaîne joueur du brussels
cède salut est aujourd'hui du coup comme
promis on va vous faire une petite
visite pour le coup on a droit de dire
que c'est une vidéo spéciale comme ils
font tous les youtube heures parce que
là pour le coup c'en est vraiment une
énorme affaire on n'a jamais fait ça sur
cette chaîne d'ailleurs donc c'est qu'on
va vous montrer les locaux faisaient ça
fait un certain temps que vous nous
voyez faire beaucoup dopé de sponsors
mais on va peut-être vous montrer à quoi
sert tout cet argent justement et dans
quoi investit on a acheté plein de
nouveaux jouets qui vont permettre de
faire des trucs super dans les
prochaines vidéos mais du coup
aujourd'hui on va vous montrer un petit
peu parce que jusqu'à présent il fallait
il faut expliquer qu'on était dans des
locaux précédents c'est un appart c'est
un appartement ont retapé effectivement
qui coûtait pas cher pas cher les choses
de les revendre pour ça qu'on l'aimé
déjà effectivement et qu'on a retapé à
notre sauce on a mis au fond vert enfin
du latin au maximum qu'on a pu payer les
corgis dérangé il ya des costumes et
voilà ont été vite encombré enfin ce
marché on était vite limité aussi
c'était quoi c'est un appart de
ce 82 carré un truc comme ça parce que
c'était un as pas là du court en fait
bon on n'a pas acheté on loue ici ça va
nous permettre de faire plein de choses
en fait faut expliquer qu on est dans
l'entrepôt où on a filmé la scène finale
de la vidéo des onze ans c'est ça du
coup et ensuite cet entrepôt qui est
évident c'est un autre pot c'est un gars
qu'on fait qui vident ont l'art ménagers
on a comme on a fait construire des murs
on a fait qu'on ferait donc tout ce que
vous allez voir laillé derrien la balade
à la base c'était vide complètement vide
et dans l'odeur du sang de mon explosion
de ses vrais feytiat celle ci s'est
complètement ouais un peu il y en a qui
font size du champagne et du coup mais
je pense l'idée ça merde et du coup je
connaisse pas voilà je pense qu'on va
vous montrer un petit peu à quoi ça
ressemble
voilà c'est parti c'est parti un rom
tour est ce qu'on fait suivez moi
d'autre que d'un de vos questions
en tout cas là on est dans le nez dans
le petit truc alors déjà c'est un truc à
la cnar avancé 2 m ouais on avance on
avance à neuf mais déjà un truc à la con
c'est qu'avant on n'avait nulle part où
recevoir les gens quand on recevait des
gens qui devaient pas le canada c'était
sur le canapé du décor là pour une fois
on ad on a d'un endroit on recevra les
jambons green que ça déjà c'est agréable
ce qu'on va commencer on va faire pièce
par pièce on va vous montrer ce qu'on
veut ce qu'on fait dans chaque pièce
ce qu'on veut faire dans chaque pièce
est un peu nouveau matos cora et on va
commencer directement par la salle
technique ce faire la bombe stocks le
matos
franck non bon alors là c'est juste la
salle technique ici le son est un peu
différent évidemment c'est une toute
petite salle c'est là au hasard c'est un
hommage au buzzer du grenier c'est parce
qu'on a tout est un peu entreposés à
larache mais voilà on a d'énormes
rangement et si on a un placard où sont
entreposés plein de matériel dont du
matériel magnifique on va en parler on
va en parler d'ailleurs il faut dire que
c'est aussi la dga schéma transition
c'est dommage
c'est alors qu'ils gardent pendant ce
temps d'avoir fait la dont dieu mais non
je suis un mec de spontané oui donc
parce que effectivement il faut
remercier black magic qui nous a fourni
pas mal de matos en fait ils nous on
récupère matters notamment une quinzaine
d'autres nouvelles caméras alors qu'il
n'est pas celle avec laquelle on tourne
là maintenant mais on va vous la montre
et après vous espériez
voilà vous la montre rang dernier qui
est une caméra génial qui va nous
permettre de faire des images vraiment
très très belle au cinéma on a un pied
dans les machines exactement on assez
sympa en fait on essaye toujours pareil
c'est quand la le on essaie un peu
d'investir pour améliorer la qualité
d'image comme autant la lumière que
l'image elle-même que les objectifs
nobles et on a vraiment quasiment tous
renouvelés absolument tout renouveler au
niveau du matin et du coup en fait ils
nous ont fourni pas mal de masques de
matos donc pour ça déjà on les remercie
et vous avez si le matin aussi bon si
vous évidemment si le matos vous
intéresse un petit peu vous avez les
liens de notre matos disponible sous la
description de la vidéo alors ce que je
vais faire on va commencer par montrer
le matos le petit bateau ce qui servira
plus tard voilà ces gens n'ont rien à
voir avec la configuration qui ont
égalisé pour les trois classiques ça
c'est les black magic micro studio
caméra alors ça c'est ce qui servira
plus tard dans les émissions du bazar
parce que sur le bazar on va avoir pas
mal d'émissions pour l'instant c'est pas
évident on est très loin d'être prêt
parce que le décor n'est pas finie
machin on vous montrera la salle ont
contourné ce genre de choses mais on a
des émissions de jeux de société 2 2
[Musique]
on a plein de projets pour l'instant on
a les caméras mais on n'a pas le décor
n'a rien d'autre donc du coup
du coup ça c'est sont là ça va servir
c'est du concret effectivement on a
aussi une fille souhaite leur bien ça
alors ça c'est un autre ministre
expliquait un site une console en fait
qui permet de servir de régis finalement
pour pour sélectionner les bonnes kendra
fin voilà qu'une une régie vidéo tout
simplement ça c'est une régie vidéo
parce qu'il faut comprendre que cette
salle dans laquelle on est c'est aussi
la salle alors on va acheté des écrans
plus tard match extra mais c'est aussi
une salle qui va nous permettre de
servir de leur régie pourquoi on va
tourner les émissions du bazar en fait
ce que la faut voir que actuellement
comment on tourne c'est à dire qu'on
tombe dans tous les angles de caméra qui
nous faut où il ya une qualité dépend
des émissions c'est là qu'il y aura du
vidéo voilà quand il y aura du multi
caméras l avantage c'est qu'on peut
réaliser en direct
en fait ça et ça se gagner du temps
montage direct voire tête voilà du live
donc dû trouver peut-être du live os x
on ne s'interdit rien tout est possible
c'est ça et donc bon là on a le sac de
la grosse caméra mais quand vous
montrera plus tard peut-être le drone
qui a servi qu'une fois qui a coupé en
deux la nique aux voilà enfin en tout
cas là autant le préciser ses vrais
formation veut plein et nick ont dans
son sens fidèle important concours vidéo
fort boyard on a tout un tas de choses
qui traînent ici c'est parce qu'il ya
des choses intéressantes non non non je
plaisante encore n'est pas ok des outils
ok bon après il ya d'autres petits trucs
ici du genre vous des anciennes l'aide
voilà ils ont intérêt personne c'est
dommage mais enfin qui simon le métro je
pense qu'on ferait une belle déco mais
c'est le néant on gare sa route qu'on a
pu voir ce que j'adore c'est un design
ouais c'est clair
bref donc voilà le guen parce que ça
c'est du coup la selle on va stocker le
matos voilà il ya rien de spécial à dire
du coup on vous a montré un petit peu le
matos qui servira plus tard
qu'est ce qu'on a ici
[Musique]
ok alors là du coup on va entrer dans je
rappelle qu'ici avait rien tous ces murs
là on les a on les a fait construire du
coup on va rentrer dans la première
salle qui est donc on va faire les sales
dans l'ordre de pandore il est pas
spécialement veut dire vétusté allez
c'est parti
waouh je rigole j'ai eu alors ici qu'est
ce que c'est on fait notre compte à
exactement c'est une salle de contenants
à un vrai c'est la salle vous avez
peut-être connaître c'est la salle où on
a tourné les gags développeurs de la
partie jeu en vrac fin du jeu en vrac
sur peter molyneux du coup qu'on a
tourné ici alors c'est vrai que pour
l'instant ça sert quand on veut faire
les développeurs
c'est con parce qu on essaye d'éviter
d'en faire en plus mais c'est que en
fait où on est en train avec en relation
avec des poses process alors vous allez
voir la chaîne pose procès si vous ne
connaissez pas cet excellent ce sont des
gens qui parlent de jeux vidéo mais en
rentrant vraiment dans l'aspect beaucoup
plus de technique du truc on est en
train de prévoir une émission avec qui
serait une espèce de jdg slash poste
process post grossesse qui permettrait
de parler de jeux vidéo on essaie en
garder un côté un peu léger mais deux en
rentrant davantage dans le détail bon
voilà ça pour l'instant c'est en cours
de ses encours de création ce sera plus
tard sur le bazar on a on est en train
de travailler premier épisode donc voilà
ça c'est une petite salle comme ça qui
est aussi accessoirement une seule
modulaire parce que du coup si on a
besoin de la rangée de virer les
tableaux de virer ça pour installer moi
j'en sais rien un décor de commissariats
on peut le faire c'est aussi davantage
c'est qu'avant quand on voulait faire
quand on vous laisse pas aller un
commissariat et on était obligé de
trouver quelque chose qui ressemble
maintenant on a une salle qu'on peut
réadapter en fonction de besoins là de
le modifier en fonction de ce qu'on veut
qu'on verra tout le temps ce qui fait
qu'on va le lier à chaque fois que c'est
la même pièce
[Rires]
[Musique]
du coup là alors ça résonne évidemment
parce que la salle n'est pas encore
traitées pour le son on est dans la
salle qui servira pour les futurs truc
du bazar exactement la salle modulable
qu'on va l'appeler comme ça et ce qui
fait que web rend on va créer un plateau
on sait pas quelle tête il y aura
définitivement mais le but c'est d'avoir
des personnes autour d'une table et puis
le fait de changer de format enfin ça
peut être du jdr ça peut être une chose
jeux de société en france on a plein
d'idées mais c'est le jeu de plateau aux
rameurs les gens qui sont concernés se
reconnaîtront enfin j'ai mal en tout cas
j'aimerais bien fait j'aimerais bien
faire ce genre de trucs mais voilà en
gros le principe d'une façon ça restera
des gens autour d'une table qu'on en
fait et ça tape derrière une table peu
importe et du coup bon là évidemment
pour l'instant rien c'est une grande
salle vide qui nous sert juste de
stockage avec les mousses le matelas
pour faire des cascades et des conneries
les gens le voient en cela que ça se
soit un décor l'émission pas terrible
mais du coup voilà le principe c'est que
la pub faire des cascades c'est trop peu
près le principe c'est que c'est dans
cette salle dans cette future salle
qu'on va faire du coût des futures
émissions qui arriveront ce bazar et les
trucs qui seront reliés à la régie dont
on parlait justement fait c'est ça c'est
ça oui et d'ailleurs on a aussi et c'est
peut-être le moment pour le montrer
parce que c'est la lumière qui éclaire
actuellement parce qu'on a pas reçu l on
a foutu des lumières dans toutes les
salles parce que sinon c'est trop sombre
évidemment pour la caméra mais on a
acheté des nouvelles lumières qui sont
vraiment trop trop cool et qui vont
beaucoup nous servir parce que un truc
qu'on travaillait jamais jusque là et
sur lequel on va essayer de travailler
maintenant c'est les lumières avant
faisait une lumière basile n'attirait
pas si je déconne c'est en finley à un
mur il ya des épisodes ont éclairé lui
on a éclairé mais le truc c'est que
voilà on avait du matériel qui n'était
pas aux deux gamins pensée pour ça voilà
c'est pas très cher
c'est ça qu'on a tant fait jusqu'à
présent on a toujours eu du mat du
matériel amateur ou amateurs semi pro tu
sais ce que je dis pas ce à un coût
très chers effectivement l éclairage est
extrêmement cher là on a essayé de
passer chez pas si on peut dire qu'on a
le pied dans le promenant je pense que
oui c'est bientôt ce je pense qu'il ya
mieux évidemment at on pu ces dernières
sera des amateurs ma vie mais non là je
pense que long terme de matériel on a
quand même bien un pied dans le cinéma
voilà c'est ça et du coup c'est
peut-être l'occasion le projet alors ça
descend ça ressemble à ça mais là c'est
triste c'est évidemment pas compter
qu'elle est mourante
on va vous montrer celle qui est branché
après donc certains lassés des trucs de
la marque alors c'est pas du tout ces
jeunes outre ces trucs de la marque nike
babel en fait c'est jim unis oui mais
voilà donc là c'est le deux parrains
donc ça aussi c'est elle qui est
vraiment de light essai de la lède essai
de la led effectivement l avantage de
l'aide c'est que alors même si c'est pas
exactement parfait dirait karim c'est
que ça permet du coup de faire des
images comme si on avait des des
gélatines dessus léger latine faut
expliquer ce que ce modèle là en
l'occurrence c'est à dire on peut écrire
et couleurs de la couleur effectivement
mais avec des références qui
correspondrait de grêle orange et lattes
et j'arrête pour faire court ce sont des
espèces de deux filtres con mais par
deux suivants en fait et qui permettent
de simuler une couleur et du coup il y
en a un qui est branché qui est juste là
quand on met donc voilà c'est la version
un parent donc c'est la moitié de celui
qu'on vous a montré précédemment donc
déjà on voir en termes d'options de
boutons de même voilà une ventilation
puisque le truc en voit tellement en
termes de lumière que ça n'a rien à voir
c'est le jour où ian y lançait le jour
et du coup on voit là les options je
découvre je connais pas encore le
matériel pour parfaire mais voilà on a
on peut accéder à ce genre voilà gel
mode on peut simuler la lumière du jour
voilà je fais n'importe quoi voilà c'est
très beau que leur mode saas et h et
fier où l attaque et là on voit
directement regardez comme c'est beau
j'ai l'impression que ça m'excite que
moi mais je suis très content donc la
regarde et on peut changer les couleurs
c'est formidable on peut créer une
ambiance tout ça au tout ça pour dire
que effectivement jusqu'à après on
éclaire et des vidéos des fois même
quand on est clair les vidéos gens par
exemple la vidéo mission impossible on
avait un peu travaillé l'éclairage
dessus là maintenant on va essayer de
davantage rail et des éclairages parce
qu'en vrai c'est vraiment un truc qui
joue énormément c'est une belle scène
c'est pas juste une belle caméra et
basta quoi c'est surtout beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de travail sur
l'éclairage et on l'a vu dans la vidéo
dès 11 ans et sait que c'est là où tu
perds mais c'est là qu'on filme aussi ça
fait chier quoi franchement c'est là où
tu sais là où en fait c'est le truc qui
bouffent le plus de temps en fait
l'éclairage parce que c'est vraiment ça
paye à la fin quand c'est bien fait
c'est j'ai certes ça fait ton image
oui mais de ses lancers longs le plus
important c'est nouvel immeuble est
évidemment du coup la salle pièce de
résistance la salle jdg que vous n'avez
pas intégralement vu jusque là on va
savoir bah c'est un petit peu relier le
borgne qui nous vient cette musique
il veut pas jouer le jeu du on découvre
sa peine mais aulas
du coup la partie jeu en rack que vous
avez déjà vu ça vous l'aviez pas vu on a
une à une borne d'arcade mais non comme
borne d'arcade
ça prend de la place s'est pas
spécialement utile mais on a une borne
d'arcade une bande the tale quoi
franchement c'est une vieille lune
viborg c'est encore en france les trucs
sont encore en francs ses ouailles
bourse sa blonde de la brosse voilà ce
que je devrais je comprends avec wild
arms wildgen well well well well je
déteste ça ce n'est pas le décor jeu en
vrac que vous avez déjà vu dans les gens
en vrac du coup là vous le voyez un
petit peu plus large maintenant
la volonté c'était de garder un esprit
chambre années 90 un petit peu c'est
pour ça que le décor il est assez
détaillé quand on regarde vraiment plein
de petits détails on a on s'est fait
chier on allait mettre des détenus a par
exemple des affiches counter strike des
trucs doom mortal kombat de mach 1 1 pc
20 pc qui marche d'ailleurs avec des
stickers sur le côté pour le côté très
bel âne avec très 90's à des vieux
magazines des dénés enfin bref c'est là
ce machin-là sept plans petits détails à
con mais ça des langues des trucs comme
ça des langues la télé qui est
fonctionnel 1 du coût qui est
effectivement on avait mis le premier
genre à qu'on a fait dans ce cadre là il
y avait un truc d'oeuvre un oav et de
dbz qui tourne en fond et du coup
personne était concentré sur ce que je
disais c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas
refait l'erreur pour le deuxième joueur
en est d'ailleurs doivent été très bon
when love était très bon effectivement
mais du coup le principe voilà c'est
alors moi personnellement la base je
voulais en plus rajouté un lit mais ça
aurait fait vraiment beaucoup de boucles
bordel spieser mira en fait c'est ça en
fait c'est quoi un petit détail un petit
détail à la con mais c'est arrête c'est
un petit détail à la con mais quand on
était en fait quand vous étiez en train
de préparer l'image et comment j'avais
juste foutu la vhs de je sais plus quel
mauvais je crois que c'était beau jacky
me semble en fonte qui tournait gt gt
vraiment j'étais assis sur ma chaise en
train de regarder le truc à côté de mon
pc je t'ai chilcot alors j'étais
tranquille je serais resté là une heure
et demie sans problème au regard des
bons trucs et à manger des céréales quoi
elle est en fait j'avais en fait c'est
que j'aime beaucoup le décor le décor
georges braque tel qu'il est là je
trouve souvent je le préfère quand même
par rapport à avant parce que déjà il ya
cet angle là qui est bien avant alors
qu'avant on était sur l'internement en
font deux pièces ouais c'était un peu
fait de bric et de broc
ça ressemblait c'était mon bureau le
premier décor de jean bracq c'était
celui qui était chez moi droit mais si
on n'a pas pensé très longtemps la
décoration tandis que la ce c'est très
très très remplis et très concentré mais
c'est il ya plein de choses en fait si
tu pointes en a eu partout tu trouves à
chaque fois une petite raie fait une
petite toile est joué il ya le joug le
cobaye tu vois c est d'ailleurs il faut
qu'on vous remercie j'ai plus leurs noms
en tête mais il faut absolument que je
m'apprête à l'inscription de vidéos
c'est qu'il ya des fans très très gentil
qui nous ont filé des tas de jeux pc en
boîte les vieux jeux pc en boîte avec la
grosse bouffe habiter de foule est dense
à son impeccable
il ya des jeux d'une rareté c'est
hallucinant et d une qualité impeccable
vraiment c'est vraiment je leur fais un
énorme merci parce que vraiment si ce
décor à la classe c'est vraiment aussi
grâce à eux du coup vraiment un énorme
merci à eux et du coup la partie gdg que
vous voyez pour la première fois que
quitte pas dans une vidéo gdg du coup
mais voilà qui a changé qui a pas mal
changé de forme pour plusieurs raisons
avant en fait le on était aussi dans une
pièce qui était un peu rectangulaire on
met le canapé était plus dans la
longueur en fait j'étais plus dans la
longueur de la pièce et ça là on l'a mis
on l'a non il était dans la largeur
plutôt là on l'a mis dans la longueur
pourquoi parce que ça nous permet une
bonne part apprend la nouvelle cameron
ont à nouveau aux objectifs qui la
volonté de faire une image un peu plus
travaillée en termes de lumière et tout
donc on voulait vraiment séparer le
canapé ne pas le plaquer contre les
étagères derrière le canapé a toujours
été plaquée sur les étagères d'un manque
de place tout simplement c'était pas une
volonté et la vue qu'on a vraiment du
recul on pourra vraiment travailler un
éclairage et avant une belle image
j'espère que ça va être le cas parce que
là on n'a qu'un temps d'insister alors
si on avait juste tourner vite fait une
critique cinéma dessus mais qu'on avait
fait un peu la rage
d'ailleurs alors bon évidemment on a mis
des posters partout sur les murs comme
avant pour pour tout ce joli petit
moment et effectivement la télé qui
hélas la grosse télé pour l'instant qui
va virer parce qu'elle est beaucoup trop
lourde on voudrait en accrocher une sur
le mur ça allait beaucoup trop lourd et
qu'est ce que je peux dire de plus c'est
que effectivement on a déchargé un petit
peu le décor en fait on aurait pu nous
ce qu'on aurait pu faire effectivement
c'est littéralement recouvrir
d'armoires tous les murs mais en fait
c'est vrai que les armoires qu'on a sont
des noirs qui sont noirs du coup elle
absorbe beaucoup la lumière est en fait
c'est que ça fait mots ça fait très
monolithique en fait ça fait vraiment
les grosses briques le mur de jeu et on
voulait quelque chose qui fasse un peu
plus chambre un peu plus naturels tels
que c'était censé être là parce que l'on
se rappelle que normalement dans les
premiers jdg tout ça c'était chez moi
c'était ma chambre mais c'était vraiment
réellement macha donc en fait et on
n'avait pas beaucoup place au fur et à
mesure on a agrandi de décor mais du
coup on voulait pas que tu vas lundi sa
logique
non mais c'est c'est qu'en fait on
voulait casser un petit peu on voulait
casser un petit peu ce côté ce que c'est
ce côté monolithique c'est pour ça qu'en
fait il y aura bon le décor vraiment
arrière c'est-à-dire le cadre principal
des idées gester quand je suis assis sur
le canapé et que ses films en face de
moi ça ça n'a pas trop changé on a remis
à peu près les trucs à la même place que
des légères variantes mais ça va pas
beaucoup changer mais ensuite pour le
reste pour les autres axes les gens ce
que je suis filmé de côté ou quand c'est
filmé sur scène ou ce genre de choses
c'est on voulait qui est un peu un truc
qui soit un peu cassé c'est à dire qu'on
a mis des étagères on a mis des morceaux
de mur où il n'ya pas de n'y a pas de
plat car il n'y a pas de jeu on a mis
plus tôt des mini armoires là plutôt que
les grandes étagères très grande
on a la latitude malades sur ce canapé
donc on suppose qu'il va y avoir encore
mais il ya plus d affiches en fond il
n'y a pas de jeu pas donc on a essayé de
changer un petit peu voilà le décor et
deux parce que si on a plus de place
mais simplement alors il ya encore
quelques jeux qui traînent là haut il ya
encore des trucs qu'on peut mais il ya
des consoles qu'on a pas arrangés mais
en fait moi ce que je voulais à tout
prix éviter ça c'était vraiment un truc
que je voulais absolument éviter ces je
voulais éviter que ça fasse le truc
collectionneurs branlette en fait c'est
c'est à dire le côté alors que les jeux
très rangée avec le petit et clair je le
côté collectionneurs pour le prochain
peut-être pas du coup je voulais
vraiment que ça fasse plus joueur que
collectionneur que tu en penses toi moi
je suis d'accord
on passe par là allez bon ici bas on est
là on est revenu sous le hangar donc
c'est pour ça que ça résonne
c'est l'heure pour notre défense est
protégée que la protection pour le jour
où le monde s'effondre war non c non c
bref c'est parce qu'on a beaucoup
d'harmonies on a un deuxième machin
comme ça à force avec tous nos vers soft
tous les machins concernant les vidéos
donc c'est bon les à stocker un peu
jolie en fait ça c'était le sol ou aussi
que tous étaient le sol où il y avait
dans la vidéo des dix ans il y avait
brel avec le trône fièrement ses l'anus
les deux allaient ensemble c'était le
seul sur lequel bob était traîné dans la
fin de la vidéo partir de la première
partie première partie du onze ans et du
contenu c'est 30 de tanus qu'on a
remonté servira probablement plus
compliments je sais juste on n 30 pour
se la péter
c'est ça c'est quoi ce matin quand un
glitch ue qui font tout à l'égout la
plus complète que tron en face à va
serrer tron tron ça va avec le nom du
méchant ni sanibroyeur de chiens au
passage juste je leur fais je leur fais
là petit peu mais je remercie la société
cds qui nous a conçu ben voilà quelqu'un
contre les murs en fait en fait tout
simplement s'est dernièrement on a fait
l'acquisition magnifique de cet escalier
qui nous empêche de mourir déjà ça c'est
pas mal et passe à la balustrade tout ça
est réalisée aussi par cds parce que
leur réussite
pendant tout le premier mois notamment
dans la vidéo cyberpunk chaque fois
qu'on voulait aller chercher un costume
on devait mettre une échelle et monter
là-haut en fait on dit on mais c'est ni
coup sûr tout juste avant que les choses
vraiment d'accord après c'est sûr j'ai
fait c'est surtout nico et jesse qui à
gauche de la caméra et que vous ne
verrez pas les pouilles mais qui est là
et qui nous a évidemment beaucoup aidé
donc ici stockage en fait à terme y aura
quoi ici en fait c'est juste des
costumes c'est les costumes les plus
urgents en fait c'est si jamais on
plutôt que de faire chier à retourner
là-bas à chaque fois on va y aller juste
après mais quand on veut ramasser les
costumes on a les chemises on a les
costumes de la vidéo du moment
en fait qu'ils sont là et puis le reste
des gros costumes et l'eau est
d'ailleurs encore un petit je joue c'est
sa savane plus en faire un truc il fasse
poète
on a acheté qu'on a acheté très quoi ça
aussi on l'a acheté très récemment et
c'est super cool
en vrai ça va nous permettre de faire de
l'éclairage d'appoint je sais pas m'en
servir
et oui effectivement donc ce sont des
des torches qu'on appelle il ya
plusieurs modes d'éclairage ont peu
changé la température et la couleur
aussi est aussi des modes pour s'amuser
comme de grands enfants que nous sommes
je vais faire ça tout de suite du verre
timidement alors ça semble en fait là
c'est le fait que c'est quand on est
vraiment sous une lumière du soleil donc
là pour le coup ça on voit pas la durée
pas trop la différence mais en fait dans
un éclair un petit peu son c'est un truc
qui est minuscule qui a une grosse
autonomie est monté aussi raymond féhou
c'est ça qu'on peut fixer
on veut ce temps que ça sera plus létale
mais ça permet de faire des mid et d
éclairage d'appoint qui sont tout petit
c'est des trucs en fait on remarque
jamais quand on regarde quand on regarde
où un film aux gens un truc qui est bien
éclairée mais il ya toujours des petits
éclairage d'appoint pour avoir juste un
petit peu d'orange qui bavent là un
petit peu de bleu de souffre un match
donc c'est des trucs qu'on va essayer de
se servir et là un truc à la con c'est
qu'en fait c'est super bien parce qu'on
a une valise avec ce jeu posé dessus et
sa recharge automatiquement les
synchroniser pour les effets que de
faire ouah il ya du toner ville abritant
nous saouler sous l'escalier rester là
voilà ça regardez là on voit on vend de
la police est là vraiment ça sein de la
police mais non et du coup voilà l
avantage c'est qu'en fait ce match on
produisait les 4 ce match est une
manette qui rechargent en plus y'a juste
il ya juste il est à ya juste à poser à
la mallette qui est là on peut saluer
pouf
ah ouais ben vous le verrez pas on va
passer du coup aux costumes l'eau alors
là c'est là où on range tout bordel ce
qu'on a énormément de costumes avant on
avait une salle de costumes qui
dégueuler vraiment mais vraiment c'était
le foutoir absoluce a dégueulé de
costumes et d'accessoires
jma n'en met pas aussi voilà c'est ça
maintenant ça des gueules aussi de
costumes et d'accessoires mais ils sont
un peu plus rangée pour l'instant que ça
va durer il compte bien [ __ ] le bordel
le plus tôt possible français ont fait
un buzz
comme ça je vous dis c'est maintenant
qu'on est devant la caméra comme ça
notre ingé son ne peut pas intervenir
ok donc là c'est la salle a en fait on
est au dessus on est sur le toit de la
pièce jdg
on est vraiment juste au dessus ces
prêts étaient prévus pour pouvoir ranger
tout ce bordel là c'est là où on stocke
tous les costumes et on a cumulé un
paquet de costumes de perruques
d'accessoires et de merde pendant s'est
ajoutée en plus c'est donc dire je t on
a fait un tri dans l'axé on a accumulé 1
pas mal de trucs pas mal de trucs sur
ces 10 11 dernières années
donc voilà alors bon pour l'instant il
ya encore du bordel et tout n'est pas
fini mais tout ça c'est pour vous
montrer en fait voilà vous et deux trucs
entier un costume
il ya ici ça se poursuit là bas au fond
on ad'autres rac il faut qu'on continue
à ranger il faut qu'on écrit par time h
etc
on a tous les accessoires sur le côté
donc ça vous donne une idée du nombre de
chiasse crown a accumulé pendant tout ce
temps là mais en fait là on a vraiment
de la place pour angers faut imaginer
que là tout ce que vous voyez ici
sachant qu'il ya ça plus à côté là bas
au fond qu'on ne voit pas tout ce que
tout ce qu'on a ici
avant c'était dans une pièce qui faisait
5 6 mètres carrés peut-être enfin ces
minuscules je sais plus mais aurait
effectivement c'était très bien sûr
rester vraiment extrêmement tasser et du
coup là maintenant on peut en fait
l'orangé mais voilà ça vous donne une
idée de tout ce qu'on a pu avoir tous
les trucs connaît là c'est vraiment le
jeu des histoires et agassi on se balade
et si on se balade et là dedans ça
serait en voie de genre hey je reconnais
ça c'est l'épisode 12 saisons trois
salles des costumes issus officiellement
impressionnant mais c'était juste pour
vous montrer ce qui est un peu le truc
qui coule sic on est au dessus de tout
nous toutes les box en fait c'est à dire
si on se déplace vers la la on est au
dessus de la fameuse salle streaming
slash salle modulable ans parce que on a
une couloir quand fait et on peut passer
au dessus de toutes les salles ça se
pratique donc c'est vraiment une gain de
place pour nous c'est parce que sinon
sinon il nous aurait fallu en fait sinon
il a loué une des salles en fait juste
pour juste pour les costumes et ça
aurait été arrêté de la perdre deux
classes en train là du coup on économise
en se mettant sur le plan fait salle
suivante juste il ya un détail et la con
c'est ça regardez au dessus voilà c'est
super classe vraiment du gadget parce
qu'on n'est jamais assez nombreux pour
avoir besoin de préciser
hier matin le maire est élevé mais on
oublie de l'utiliser des fois aussi ses
classes et on ne dit jamais voilà mais
ces classes et on l'a mais on l'a
exactement sortie salle suivante
et du coup la salle fonds vert qui est
vraiment
c'est beaucoup plus grande candeur
beaucoup plus grande qu'avant
effectivement elle n'est pas immense se
serait même moi je l'aimais même
maintenant que de tourner je me dis
[ __ ] il aurait fallu la faire encore
plus deux fois plus grosse mais du coup
faut voir qu'avant on avait l'équivalent
de 11,2 de ce mur là on avait ce mur là
qui étaient en fonds qui du coup était
éclairée du fonds si maintenant on a on
a deux pans de mur et on a ce qui
s'appelle un cyclo c'est à dire que
c'est les bords sont arrondis toute la
salle est un monde et donc on ne voit
pas en un pas d'angle en fait on a
vraiment ce côté coup d il ya plus
d'angle dans la pièce il ya on a mis des
treuils en pour pouvoir accrocher des
éclairages sur lesquels vont prendre son
ami d'un ami du gaffeur malo terme sera
des drapeaux du ciné fall cissé dû
siffler c'est quand même trop voilà
voilà
mais qui pour l'instant c'est pas
parfait c'est pas parfait en phase de
recherche et développement on voit qu'il
ya encore des halos de lumière sur le
fond vert qu'il faut arranger il ya bon
plein de choses toujours pareil se sont
tus fait 80% du travail et puis les 20%
qui reste c'est des trucs les plus loin
faire mais déjà ça nous permet de
baisser là dessus qu'on a tourné la
vidéo si bertin justement en fait les
cette taille de fonds vers nous permet
d'avoir afin d'utiliser une nouvelle
technique du coup mais d'avoir d'abord
avant ça on va peut-être montré le la
grosse caméra
voilà mes caisses mais qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est ce que c'est que cet engin
ça c'est notre future caméra on est déjà
tourné cyberpunk avait d'ailleurs d'un
autre elle est à nous elle est la nôtre
et on a fait des super image a notamment
celles qu'on a tourné dans le champ là
était vraiment magnifique
c'était avec de meilleurs objectifs
c'est avec le même objectif certes mais
ça fait quand même nom c'est quand même
une caméra cinéma qui finit machine
aimant et qui permet de tourner en black
magic pro donc d'avoir comment un
éventail de possibilités énorme à la
colo voir on repart en train trop
rentrer dans les détails techniques mais
voilà tout ça pour dire qu'on peut faire
une image qui va jusqu'à 4,6 cas
attention et et voilà on peut avoir une
gamme de deux enfin pour l'étalonnage
c'est parfait quoi ouais du coût et du
coup encore une fois merci black magic
qui nous ont fourni ce matos en plus des
trucs dont je vous avais parlé un petit
peu plus tôt et on a aussi un elder
crohn alors ccl l'île de hull crohn et
de ça ressemble à helder strohl mais du
coup s'il qui permet de faire de faire
des allers retours on l'a pas utilisé
parce qu'on on l'a monté meilleur en
fait mais ça va permettre notamment de
faire des mouvements de caméra si tu
veux un peu automatisé des mouvements
des frères grimm tout simplement on va y
venir juste après hélas pas le droit de
parler boop
voilà donc le truc qui est pratique
c'est qu'on peut faire des travellings
automatisé pour voir mes dépositions et
le truc qui est génial c'est qu'on peut
se déplacer dans tous les accents fait
finalement on peut pas noté tilter est
réglé la mise au point ouais c'est sûr
trappage de pointe où ça s'est passé
comment fait le futur entre un
travelling et un zoom c'est vraiment
deux choses complètement différentes qui
n'ont rien à voir
et avant où on avait tendance à pas
faire de beaucoup de travelling dans les
vidéos parce que faire du travelling
c'est compliqué parce que cacher ou
alors il faut une caméra il faut passer
en utilisera une vraie droid est vrai
rails de travelling la cena toute une
logistique as assez complexe parce qu'on
a utilisées pour la vidéo des dix ans
mais du coup on peut pas se permettre de
faire ça à chaque tournoi ce qu'il faut
aussi bon alors on entre vraiment dans
les détails techniques mais gens quand
on a
une personne qui suit une autre personne
au fait qu' avec un stabilisateur de
caméras mais qui est à la main donc
c'est à dire avec un stabilisateur
je commence à peine mais c'est pas la
même gerval guibal voilà c'est pas la
même chose qu'un vrai travelling fait
sur des vraies rails tous les pans de
matériel par exemple ça tu peux pas le
match ont globalement fait la caméra est
trop massive est trop lourde donc c'est
pour les appareils photos c'est possible
mais elle a en l'occurrence on peut pas
du tout quoi et puis oui comme tu disais
ouais c'est ces conflits aussi parce que
il faut qu'une personne à côté qui
pointe en fait qu'il fasse la mise au
point donc c'est pour ça que ce matériel
c'est génial parce que bon là ça permet
de tout automatiser quoique et du coup
bah justement dans cette salle l'idée
c'est alors c'est un truc on essaie
évidemment pas fini mais c'est quelque
chose sur lequel on est en train de
bosser c'est le monde à gauche la gauche
c'est le code
ouais alors c'est presque du tout mais
c'est fut enfin ça rentre dans cette
famille qui s'appelle le virtual caméra
hirise si je me trompe
virtual pollution voilà c'est la
production d'une version hybride ce qui
fait que comment on utilise comme en
l'occurrence pour notre système à nous
un tracker veille qui se creuse il se
trouve ici voilà qui permet de traquer
la position de la caméra dans la pièce
on a deux récepteurs qui trouve ici donc
c'est il y en aura quatre ferme
effectivement et ce sont les mêmes
utilisés pour le htc veille tout
simplement le casque vert fait par htc
et du coup ces informations on peut les
envoyer sur unreal nous avons jordan qui
nous permet d'obtenir de réaliser ses
plans via cette technologie a regardé
comme c'est formidable la caméra est en
train de bouger
et elle est synchronisé avec les images
du commandant un rendu 3d en temps réel
en fait et dans une ride ce qui permet
de synchroniser un personnage qui sera
incrusté sur fond vert
alors là pour l'instant l état n est pas
branché il n'y a pas de cas ne s'est pas
branché alors dit donc ce qui fait que
la pour l'instant je suis je suis sur le
fond vert mais on ne voit pas là on
filme pas réellement fait mais par
contre les mouvances ont vraiment craqué
c'est à dire car la caméra bouge c'est
retranscrit en direct dans le moule en
direct dans l'indre il en fait c'est ça
leur donne tu veux tu peux expliquer
comment ça marche
du coup la con à dire en fait on n'a pas
les câbles donc c'est pas de bol pour
montrer aux voyelles et parce qu'on est
dans l'adresse mais sinon boston on a un
câble qui partent de la caméra
et qui arrive dans la carte du pc donc
une decklink de blackmagic pour faire
l'acquisition de du flux vidéo et donc
on peut avoir une prévision en temps
réel ce qui est super pratique pour
pouvoir cadrer tout ça ce qui permet de
faire des effets spéciaux plus vite
quelque part parce qu'on peut avoir déjà
une prévision et ensuite une fois qu'on
sait que le point était bon on appuie
sur le bouton de rendu et c'est
vachement rapide aussi parce que c'est
un moteur de jeu vidéo donc du coup bah
ça s'est lui rendu en temps réel même si
on peut faire un rendu un peu plus long
qui est un peu plus détaillé tout ça
mais ça reste quand même vachement
rapide un autre truc qu'on n'a pas
encore mis en place parce qu'on n'a pas
les câbles c'est le petit écran qu'on
voilà qui permet aussi de voir l'image
de rendu quasiment finale sur cet écran
mais on n'a pas les câbles et du coup
c'est vachement pratique ça permet aussi
de faire plein de trucs parce que par
exemple admettons
on dit oui le plot là il fait chier bas
je peux le prendre à elle bougeait et du
coup il n'y a pas besoin de refaire un
rendu de faire des trucs super chien on
peut aller super vite pour mettre en
place le niveau et on peut faire plein
d'autres trucs vachement cool comme
créer les niveaux ensemble multijoueur
quelque part et tout ça est très cool
au delà de ça c'est aussi ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que par elle a en fait on
voit dans déjà ça en fait ça nous ouvre
fort qu'un gros problème qu'on aime
qu'on a et qu'on avait toujours et qu'on
aura encore probablement dans les gg
c'est que quand on veut je sais vraiment
le faire un vaisseau spatial
c'est compliqué à trouver en vrai
vaisseau spatial donc là maintenant on
va pouvoir modéliser dans une ride grâce
aux à 7 2 avril un vaisseau spatial et
ensuite on voit par exemple là on voit
que george est pas là on voit qu'à une
lumière rouge qui qui qui sort de là
qu'est une lumière rose qui sort de là
qu'il ya un une lumière bleue qui sort
de là donc pour travailler notre lumière
sa facilité de travail
voilà donc on sait on voit dans la seine
parce qu on nous place ensuite dans la
seine on voit à peu près où les tutos tu
fais toi tu vois où est-ce qu'on doit
placer les lumières sur le fond vert
pour que le jeu la personne en vrai
match avec ce qu'elle en fait si on veut
travailler avec une autre couleur on
peut changer les couleurs de unreal et
puis la couleur d'union par exemple le
passé de rouge à verre et sur le plateau
on peut éclairer envers ce serait super
sur un fond vert
mais non mais voilà on pouvait le faire
on peut le faire c'est ça qui est
pratique et
et du coup on peut c'est ce qui fait que
ça améliore la qualité d'incrustations
parce que on mate vraiment avec la
source
on a sous les yeux on a une vraie
prévisions prévisualisation du produit
fini c'est bon c'est toujours pareil
même façon nous quand on veut tourner
dès qu'on veut tourner un truc genre qui
se passe en forêt ou dans un château ça
va c'est facile mais dès qu'on cherche
dès qu'on veut faire genre vous êtes à
new york que bon fougères c'est
difficile quoi donc
mais là maintenant de la même temps ce
sera ce sera davantage facile ça a pris
du temps bonjour donne quand même pour
parce que c'est en fait le truc c'est
que tu as dû bricoler à ce qu'il y ait
personne ne l'a fait avant en fait très
peu de gens passeraient pas dire il ya
des gens qui en fait le souci c'est que
pour l'instant il n'y a pas encore de
solution clé en main pour ainsi dire
donc du coup bon même si on est un peu
guidée par certains certaines
documentation donnerait où certains
certains tutoz sur internet passe est un
peu le saut dans l'inconnu
donc c'était un peu stressant mais bon
au final maintenant enfin à l'instant t
je sais que j'ai un truc qui fonctionne
à peu près même si j'ai prévu de
racheter point pas mal de fonctions pour
pas pour faciliter la production qui
aussi pour que pour continuer à faire
des effets spéciaux qui sont pas dire
mieux mais des trucs qui sont un peu
plus un peu plus chiadé donc c'est un
peu à larache mais ça s'est fait avec du
matériel facilement disponibles donc les
traqueurs weill qui sont à la base se
fait plus faire du jeu vidéo quoi mais
il ya d'autres technologies qui existent
et on est en train de regarder ça pour
voir si on ne peut pas avoir une autre
solution de tracking ou des trucs qui
sont encore mieux là encore on parle que
de la vidéo essentiellement mais il ya
aussi tout l'aspect sont évidemment
chaque pièce doit être traitée et ne
sont pas toutes encore la pièce jdg elle
est en cours de traitement à la pièce la
future pièce bazar rien n'est fait celle
là on a fait énormément fait il ya eu un
énorme travail sur le son est notre ingé
son énormément galéré parce que c'est
extrêmement compliqué on essaie très
hauts plafonds en fait c'est extrêmement
hauts plafonds comparé aux autres pièces
et la pièce à l'évident fait c'est à
dire que c'est des gros mur plat qui
renvoie qui renvoie les ondes alors moi
je sais pas comment ça marche mais du
coup il a fallu mettre des mousses ex
terrasse rayé fabriquer tous les
coffrages à toutes les plaques
avec alix et jesse enfin voler ces trois
là dessus
[Musique]
le nom
pour un rendu qui est très correct vous
attendez à quoi le fait du bon voilà bah
c'était petite présentation alors
vraiment rien n'était c'est évidemment
rien et éclairer là on appris que les
éclairages au pif pour éclairer les
plafonds heureusement parce que si l'on
regarde pas si dit complètement voilà
évidemment les l'image en fait de là on
n'a pas du tout travaillé là on était
vraiment en mode ans circule dans les
circuits dans les studios c'était pour
vous montrer un petit peu où est-ce que
qu'est ce qu'on a fait pourquoi la vidéo
cyberpunk est arrivé avec un mois de
retard
typiquement sait on attendait il ya pas
mal de malentendus du matos pendant une
éternité
c'est ça aussi à cause du covilha il a
fallu aussi bien construire ce machin de
2,0 en fait le truc où est le truc avec
un baril sur fond vert tout ça c'est il
y avait toujours un problème est
toujours un truc allait s'adapter à
exclure toute façon c'est compliqué
c'est toujours ça quand tu fais quelque
chose de nouveau il avait deux roues ont
travaillé du nouveau matos qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de maîtriser machin qu'on me
compare à d'habitude donc donc voilà
c'est un bon déjà c'est pour ça je
justifie le retard dans la dernière
vidéo mais il maintenait en vie c'est
pas fini on continue ta tion on est
toujours là on continue à renouveler le
matos petit à petit donc évidemment le
retard va continué à s'accumuler
mais là vu que voilà le comment les
locaux commencent à devenir présentable
on va dire que c'était important de
montrer à vous montrer voilà à quoi se
ressemblent qu'est-ce qu'on fait
derrière en coulisses vous voilà c'est
ça vous montrez qu'est ce qu'on fait et
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec avec avec
toutes ces au ps et sponso et ça nous
serve à financer tout ça et encore une
fois merci merci d'accepter déjà quoi
qu'on en fasse et d'avoir des montants
parce qu'on sait que souvent d'être très
très bon retour sur les différentes fond
de soi qu'on fait ou qu'on essaie de
travailler un petit peu mais en tout cas
ça voulait en fait tous ces petits
machins que ce soit les éclairages le
machin qu'elle fait le rail à travelling
le caméra les nouveaux objectifs
on n'a évidemment pas tout montré il ya
aussi draps et des drapeaux des
éclairages des nouvelles gélas des
feuilletons tout des petits accessoires
qu'on va pas vous montrer plus il
faudrait vous explique un parent à quoi
ça sert mais tous ces petits trucs en
fait ça va nous donner des outils
différents qui nous permettront de faire
des images plus belles de de faire des
plans qu'on fait pas d'habitude parce
que c'est vrai que on s'est enfermé dans
un schéma mental où c'était genre plans
fixes plans fixes plans fixes plan fixe
parce qu'on a l'habitude de faire ça
parce qu'on voit des choses 3 par des
fois on va dire ça parce qu'on n'a pas
les moyens de faire autre chose ces cinq
là on s'est ouvert des possibilités
enfin on verra avec le temps mais du
coup ça nous fait cogiter ça nous donne
des idées de projets à travers j'ai déjà
bien sûr alors évidemment après on va
pas tomber dans le syndrome anthony
daniels jeu de méchas mais non mais non
mais c'est pas du tout méchant c'est
vraiment on va pas enfin on va pas
tomber dans le syndrome gens on veut
remettre huit mois pour faire une vidéo
vous inquiétez pas assez c'est juste que
tout ça nous permet de nous ouvrir
différents ça nous permet de nous ouvrir
des routes ça nous donne des outils
différents fait ça me donne des outils
différents qu'on n'avait pas avant
et là où avant on aurait juste fait un
truc entre deux plans fixes maintenant
on va pouvoir le faire on va peut-être
mettre des petits mouvements de
travelling on va peut-être mettre des
caméras qui pas note on va peut-être m
on aura des meilleurs fondeurs aussi
typiquement des vidéos comme alien par
exemple la vie une un truc un truc une
vidéo sur aliens avant qu'on voulait
faire depuis très longtemps avant on ne
pouvait pas avant on pouvait pas
maintenant on essaie de favoriser les
décors réels quant aux mesures qui
existent voilà mais reviennent c'est
impossible d'observer la meilleure salle
de pinball en lumière noire un peu
futuriste sera jamais à vienne à
l'évidence c'est ça et du coup
maintenant avec ce truc de fond vert on
ne pourra ça va nous offrir ça va nous
ouvrir des choses qu'on ne pouvait pas
faire avant du coup ben c'est fini ça on
l'a toujours faire on n'a jamais trop
communiquer là dessus on a toujours
cette époque un peu notre matériel tout
rond la renouveler pour pour passer à la
hd à l'époque ensuite à la 4k tout ça
c'est qu'on essaie régulièrement mais
c'est détruire des choses qu'on montre
pas forcément mais là en fait on s'est
dit ça serait cool de le montrer parce
que vraiment en fait on a tous fait d'un
seul coup en fait on a changé le monde a
changé de décor on a changé le lieu on a
changer les fonds verts on a des du
nouveau matos du nouvel éclairage donc
venant comme tout changer en même temps
on s'est dit que ça serait cool vous
montrer simplement
bref voilà bah du coup merci d'avoir
suivi cette vidéo vraiment très
différente par rapport à ce qu'on fait
d'habitude ne vous inquiétez pas une
vraie vidéo qu'on est en train de
travailler pendant ce temps là on a fini
de le story board et cet aprem
normalement donc et puis donc on
continue à bosser pendant ce temps là
pour évidemment utiliser tout ça pour
que vous le voyez en action et puis
merci encore à black magic qui nous a
financé une partie du matos que vous
avez pu apercevoir dans cette vidéo
notamment la grosse caméra et les
petites plus tôt ainsi que des petits
accessoires et vous avez encore une fois
les liens sur description ça vous
intéresse au niveau technique
et puis pour le reste à bientôt pour
d'autres vidéos sur la chaîne jour de
gagné salut à tous